Wir sind in der PC-12.
Und wir fliegen nach Gabarone
mit einer schwer kranken Frau.
Die Ursache
ist eine Schwangerschaft,
die nicht mehr intakt ist -
d.h., das Kind ist tot.
Das Kind wird dann entfernt werden.
Sie ist schwer krank.
Sie hat ein Nierenversagen.
Sie braucht intensive
medizinische Betreuung hinterher.
Ich bin Optimist.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass wir sie
während des Fluges stabilisieren.
In Gabarone
können sie das weiterführen.
So kann sie geheilt werden.
Frühmorgens in Kansas, USA.
Die beiden Sturmjäger
Dominic und Sascha
haben gestern in den Wetterdaten
eine Tornadozelle entdeckt.
1'000 km - kann das sein?
Das muss mehr sein.
- Ja.
Wir müssen etwas weiter
als Denver fahren.
Und dann sind wir
auf der sicheren Seite.
Jetzt sind wir 2 Std. früher
unterwegs als geplant.
Wir sind hier, um Gewitter zu jagen.
Wir haben gut geplant.
Dominic hat Sascha vor elf Jahren zu
Hause in der Schweiz kennengelernt.
Mit dieser dreiwöchigen Tornadojagd
durch den Mittleren Westen
erfüllen sich die beiden Stormchaser
jetzt einen Lebenstraum.
Wir treffen uns in der Schweiz
immer wieder zum Stormchasen.
Sascha ist der Götti meines Sohnes.
Ich kann mich eigentlich
nur lobend über ihn äussern.
Du darfst nichts anderes.
- Richtig, ja.
Sascha ist ein Daueroptimist.
Das ist sehr positiv.
Es kann
noch so beschissen aussehen,
er sieht immer
das Positive an der Sache.
Das liegt in meiner Natur.
Sascha kann sehr euphorisch sein.
Er hat eine praktische Intelligenz.
Wenn er etwas sieht, weiss er,
er will es so und so machen.
Ich bin eher einer,
der fundamental wissen will,
warum ich etwas mache.
Die feuchtwarme Suppe drückt hoch.
Was die Winde betrifft,
haben wir eine Konvergenz.
Die Winde führen zusammen.
Und dort
wird es für uns heute spannend.
Unsere unterschiedlichen Haltungen
machen ein gutes Team aus.
Wenn ich einen Partner
an meiner Seite hätte,
der genau gleich denken würde,
wären wir uns sicher einig,
aber ob wir einen Tornado
finden würden, weiss ich nicht.
Das Frühstück im Nirgendwo
ist Nebensache.
Die zwei Sturmjäger
lassen die Wetterlage
keine Sekunde aus den Augen.
Das Problem ist die Zugrichtung.
Die ist so wie jetzt.
- Wo ist der Triple Point?
Den habe ich hier ausgemacht.
Der Hagelkern kommt weiter rüber.
Oder bessere Luft.
Gibt es schon einen Kern?
- Hier ist ein Hagelkern.
Bleibt der nicht hängen?
- Doch.
Eigentlich bleibt er hängen,
es sei denn, er hat ein Eigenleben.
Wir warten noch 5 Min.
und essen fertig.
Dann fahren wir in diese Richtung.
Sie haben gerechnet,
verglichen und spekuliert.
Und jetzt
sind sie sich fast ganz sicher:
In der Nähe von Ogallala, Nebraska,
entwickelt sich eine Gewitterzelle
zu einem Tornado.
Ogallala.
1 Std. wird angegeben.
Wir haben eine Zelle entdeckt,
die unterwegs ist.
Sie kommt in gute Luftmassen hinein.
Ich denke,
es ist ein mutiger Entscheid.
Wir können zu dieser Zelle fahren.
Oder diese hier abfangen.
Ich denke,
es ist ein guter Entscheid.
Zur richtigen Zeit
am richtigen Ort sein -
darauf kommt es jetzt an.
Da sieht man den Regen.
Entspannter geht es bei Familie Moser
in Südostasien zu und her.
Seit vier Jahren wohnen
Daniel und Deborah in Osttimor -
einem der ärmsten Länder der Welt.
Daddy muss arbeiten gehen.
Mach's gut.
Machst du noch eine Runde mit Daddy?
Der 34-jährige Berner
arbeitet als Missionspilot
bei der christlichen
Hilfsorganisation MAF.
Deborah kümmert sich
um den gemeinsamen Sohn Eli.
Eli schimpft manchmal,
wenn Daddy geht.
Ich glaube,
er vermisst ihn oder möchte mit.
So.
Wir öffnen das Tor für Daddy.
- Nein.
Tschüss, tschüss.
Am Abend kommt Daddy wieder.
Ich wünsche euch einen guten Tag.
Hier in Osttimor
bleibt die ausgebildete Heilpädagogin
tagsüber zu Hause.
Einen Kuss schicken.
Gut.
Jetzt geht Daddy arbeiten.
Die Gegebenheiten sind anders.
Als Mama ist man viel zu Hause.
Es ist ja nicht so,
dass nichts zu tun ist,
wenn man
mit den Kindern zu Hause ist.
Es läuft viel bei uns,
nicht wahr, Eli?
Eli, ich habe es schon gereinigt.
Schau mal. Es ist leer.
Wir müssen es wieder auffüllen?
Gehst du es auffüllen?
Ein ganz Kleines.
Da muss man ganz sanft sein.
Mjamm, mjamm, mjamm.
- Ganz sanft, Eli.
Ganz sanft. Tun wir es wieder rein?
Ich weiss, du möchtest noch schauen.
In der Schweiz ... Vielleicht
ist es eine falsche Vorstellung.
Ich glaube,
in der Schweiz würde ich mit Eli,
wenn er unzufrieden ist, mit dem
Kinderwagen nach draussen gehen.
Das geht hier nicht. Es gibt keine
Strassen, wo man das tun könnte.
Es ist auch viel zu heiss.
Du kannst die Steine hier reinlegen.
Hier in den Eimer.
Wir werfen keine Steine auf
Camilas Veranda. Das mag sie nicht.
Es gibt keine Spielplätze.
Man kann nicht raus
und andere Mütter treffen.
Das gibt es nicht.
Man muss sich anders organisieren.
Das fehlt mir manchmal sehr.
Deborahs Familie und Freunde
leben mehr als 12'000 km entfernt.
Habibi.
Jetzt wärst du fast runtergefallen.
* Eli jammert. *
Du Schlitzohr.
Es ist manchmal sehr anstrengend.
Ich vermisse meine Freundinnen
und meine Familie.
Diese Menschen sind schon lange
mit mir unterwegs und ich mit ihnen.
Die kann man nicht einfach ersetzen.
Und auch bei Freundschaften,
die man hier knüpft,
muss man sich früher oder später
verabschieden.
Im Team gehen Leute weiter. Auch bei
Freundschaften mit Einheimischen.
Das heisst nicht, dass man deswegen
keine Freundschaften knüpft.
Das finde ich sehr anstrengend.
In Argentinien,
genauer in Puente del Inca,
steht dem Schweizer Ballonpiloten
Stefan Zeberli
die wohl abenteuerlichste Fahrt
seines Lebens bevor.
Gemeinsam mit 50 anderen
Ballonpiloten aus aller Welt
will Stefan auf 7'000 m Höhe
die Anden überqueren.
Bis jetzt habe ich alle Sauer-
stoffflaschen von Josef gesehen.
Ich glaube,
ich gebe die alle runter.
Dann haben wir ein bisschen Platz.
Die Ausrüstung ist erst
vor ein paar Stunden angekommen.
Es ist cool,
dass die Ballons hier sind.
Die Lastwagen
haben sie in der Nacht hochgelassen.
Ich war mir nicht sicher,
ob das klappt.
Etwas weniger cool sind nach wie vor
die vielen Unklarheiten.
Es sieht nicht gut aus.
Ich suche noch
meine Sauerstoffflaschen.
Wir haben sie im März
nach Spanien mitgeschickt.
Wenn sie nicht da sind,
werden wir nicht fahren.
Der Korb ist da.
Ich muss dort drin suchen.
Wir können
den ganzen Müll rausschaffen.
Vielleicht ist es unter dem Müll.
Hier ist viel Zellophan.
Gestern hat das schlechte Wetter
für dicke Luft gesorgt.
Heute soll es besser werden.
Aber ohne Sauerstoffflaschen
nützt das alles nichts.
Wer hat die Ballons gepackt?
War das Josef oder eine Tochter?
Ich habe dir eine Flasche gegeben,
die vielleicht geht.
Die kleine?
- Ja. Zeig sie mir mal.
Nein. Auch nicht.
(In dem Moment war es eine
grosse Stresssituation für mich.)
Da habe ich schon überall geschaut.
Aber ...
(Ich nutze ein relativ komplexes
System der Sauerstoffspeisung.)
(Aber das kann ich
nur mit Flaschen betreiben.)
Für was für ein System ist das?
- Keine Ahnung.
Die kann ich nicht brauchen.
(Sie hatten zu lange Hälse.)
(Sie hatten zwar dasselbe Gewinde,
aber der Anschluss passte nicht.)
Ich fahre nicht, wenn wir nicht ...
Was für eine Scheisse.
Ich habe zwei Flaschen
runtergeschickt - beide nicht hier.
(Ich dachte, das könne nicht sein.)
(Ich habe alles nach Spanien
geschickt. Dort wurde es verpackt.)
(In Container.)
(Und in Argentinien
ist das Zeug nicht mehr da.)
(Das kann ich nicht einordnen.)
Wer hat das Material
in Spanien gepackt?
Warst du dabei?
Wir haben zwei Zweiliterflaschen
mitgeschickt.
Mit dem Ballon.
Wenn die nicht hier sind,
kann ich nicht fliegen.
Das ist ein hoher Berg.
Mittlerweile sucht Stefan seit 2 Std.
nach seinen Sauerstoffflaschen.
(Wir waren so weit.
Die Wetterlage passte perfekt.)
(Wenn es dann an einer Sauer-
stoffflasche scheitern würde ...)
Ja?
- Gefunden?- Gefunden.
Er hat wohl gerade die Flaschen
gefunden. Das wäre optimal.
Wem gehört die?
- Keine Ahnung.
Die war in einem Karton drin.
(Es waren amerikanische Systeme.)
(Die könnten passen.)
Es ist nicht diese. Aber die geht.
Der St. Galler
sieht eine Möglichkeit.
Die amerikanische Flasche könnte
auf seinen Schweizer Schlauch passen.
Nein. No.
It's too small.
It's a different type.
It's american style.
Nein. It's too small.
(Ich bin jemand,
der nicht einfach aufgibt.)
(Zu diesem Zeitpunkt war es für mich
nie ein Thema, aufzugeben.)
(Ich fragte mich:
"Was ist die nächste Möglichkeit?")
... to put down ...
It's an easy one.
- It's easier, yes.
So ... then Chris ...
Bist du einverstanden, wenn wir
hier schneiden und das machen?
Ich kann es abdichten. Okay?
Okay, then we'll do that.
Stefan will seinen Schlauch
so manipulieren,
dass er
auf ein spanisches Gewinde passt.
Es ist dasselbe Gewinde.
Vielleicht kann ich es befestigen.
Bring schnell den Regler.
Der Perfektionist,
der immer alles minutiös plant,
muss ausgerechnet jetzt
improvisieren.
Ich hole mein Isolierband.
Auch wenn dabei nicht alle verstehen,
was genau er da tut.
Gerade noch rechtzeitig
zum Sonnenaufgang
kann Stefan
seine Sauerstoffversorgung testen.
Ich habe eine Flasche.
Ja.
* Erleichtertes Ausatmen *
Nun ist auch er bereit
für den Startschuss
zur grossen Überfahrt.
Auf dem Flugplatz Amlikon
im Kanton Thurgau
ist weit und breit
noch keine Sonne zu sehen.
Für Jonas Langenegger
spielt das aber keine Rolle.
Heute hat er sein Flugzeug verpackt
und will damit verreisen.
Hast du den Fahrzeugausweis
noch angeschaut?- Nein.
Wie schwer ist er?
- Ich habe nicht nachgeschaut.
Fahrzeugausweis -
das ist noch so ein Punkt.
Für den letztjährigen Weltmeister
geht es heute mit zwei Freunden
ins Trainingscamp nach Deutschland -
vorausgesetzt,
der Fahrzeugausweis taucht auf.
Die haben doch sowieso keine Ahnung.
Aber es ist vorhanden.
Hier sehe ich auch nichts.
Hast du ihn?
- 10 Std. später.
Ich habe ihn. Er ist
in der Flugzeugakte drin - super.
Wer hat gesagt,
da drin ist er nicht?
Es ist nicht normal,
dass ein Fahrzeugausweis ...
* Dynamische Musik *
(Für die Schweizer Meisterschaften
ist dieses Training
besonders wichtig für mich.)
(Ich kann mir
Zeit fürs Training nehmen.)
(Bei vielen Sachen denke ich noch:
"Es ist noch nicht so,
wie es sein sollte.)
(Ich muss das Vertrauen haben,
zu fliegen.)
(Und ... äh ... ich möchte auch
die Bestätigung von anderen,
dass es von unten
vernünftig aussieht.)
Hallo, Linda.
- Hey.
Alles gut?
- Ja.
Hast du neues Spielzeug?
Mein Lieblingsweltmeister.
Jonas will hier die Figuren
der höchsten Flugkategorie Unlimited
erlernen.
Hilfe erhofft er sich vom Trainer
der deutschen
Segelkunstflug-Nationalmannschaft.
George Dörder
ist eine Koryphäe im Segelkunstflug.
Hallo, George.
- So, jetzt, Jonas.
Ich grüsse dich.
- Wieder so viele Gesichter hier.
Wie geht es euch?
Seid ihr gut hergekommen?- Gut, ja.
Ich freue mich, dass er den Übergang
in die Unlimited macht.
Das wird nicht ganz einfach sein.
Aber er hat gute Anlagen
und ein gutes Flugzeug.
Wenn er gut angeleitet wird,
wird er sich in der Schweiz
relativ schnell nach vorne arbeiten,
auch in der Unlimited.
Für den Aufstieg
in die nächsthöhere Kategorie
muss Jonas ein Programm
mit vorgegebenen Figuren fliegen.
Wir zeichnen hier
ein klassisches Programm.
Hier sind die einzelnen Figuren.
Das ist z.B. eine gerissene Rolle
auf den Rücken.
Auf dem Rücken,
dann wieder gestossen zurück.
Das ist in dieser Klasse
das Spezielle - das habe ich
noch nie vorher trainiert.
Es ist für mich
die grösste Herausforderung,
diese zu trainieren.
Das Schweizer Team
war in letzter Zeit sehr erfolgreich.
Niemand zweifelt daran, dass Jonas
mit der Konkurrenz mithalten kann.
Er ist ein Mensch
mit extrem viel Talent.
Letztes Jahr konnte er an der WM
sehr gut punkten.
Jetzt ist er in einer neuen Klasse.
Mal schauen, wie das geht.
Er muss neue Figuren und neue
Abläufe lernen. Aber das packt er.
* Dynamische Musik *
Jonas
wird in seinem neuen Segelflugzeug
auf knapp 1'600 m gezogen.
Dort klinkt er sich aus.
Und jetzt
trägt ihn nur noch der Wind.
* Dynamische Musik *
Aber was für die meisten
imposant aussieht,
hat für Trainerlegende George Dörder
noch viel Luft nach oben.
Gnadenlos spricht er seine
Manöverkritik auf ein Diktiergerät.
Die Schnauze höher nehmen.
Richtung Süden.
Insgesamt meiner Meinung nach
sogar ein bisschen zu flach.
Nach 25 Min.
ist Jonas zurück auf dem Boden
und hört sich die Kritik an.
Da war ein ordentlicher Schlenker
drin - besonders bei der Ausleitung
mit einem grossen Schiebewinkel.
Und du warst zu flach.
Du hast etwas zu früh gestoppt.
Nicht so gut. Aber eben.
Es ist schwierig,
so etwas unvorbereitet zu fliegen.
Ich habe mich einfach reingesetzt.
Ich bin ein paar Figuren geflogen
und habe immer überlegt,
was als Nächstes kommt.
Es war der erste Flugtag.
Jonas hat noch drei Monate Zeit.
Dann tritt er
bei der Schweizer Meisterschaft
gegen die Besten der Besten an.
* Exotische Flötenmusik *
Die Farm von Misha Kruck
und Christian Gross
liegt im Okavango-Delta -
eine kleine Oase mitten in Botswana.
(Christian Gross) Unsere Aussicht
hat man nicht gesehen.
Es war alles dicht bewachsen.
Wir haben alles gerodet.
Aufgeräumt. Und dann gebaut.
Die beiden Weltenbummler haben
hier im afrikanischen Okavango-Delta
vor sechs Jahren
die Okavango Air Rescue gegründet -
eine Rettungsflugwacht
ähnlich der Schweizer Rega.
Als wir 2011
zum ersten Mal hier waren,
hatte es kurz vorher
einen sehr dramatischen
Flugzeugabsturz im Delta gegeben.
Alle Menschen, die in der Maschine
waren, kamen ums Leben.
Es hätten Leute überleben können,
wenn Hilfe dagewesen wäre.
Uns wurde die Aufgabe
praktisch in die Arme gelegt:
"Warum macht ihr nicht
eine Rettungsflugwacht auf?"
Irgendwann haben wir gesagt:
"Ja, warum eigentlich nicht?"
Sie macht Gott sei dank
das Ärztliche.
Und du machst Gott sei dank
das Geschäftliche.
Das ergänzt sich zu 100 %.
Die Okavango Air Rescue
hat mittlerweile 20 Mitarbeitende.
Mit einer PC-12 fliegt sie
24 Std. am Tag Rettungseinsätze.
Christian
will seinen Betrieb ausbauen
und bald ein zweites Flugzeug kaufen.
Darum braucht sein Team neue Piloten.
Die werden vom italienischen
Chefpiloten Aldo instruiert.
Wir müssen
drei weitere Piloten anstellen.
Darum zeige ich ihm heute
das Flugzeug - die PC-12.
Er hat noch nie eine gesehen.
Dann muss er sein Training machen,
um die Fluglizenz
für diese Maschine zu bekommen.
(Zuerst zeige ich ihm ein paar
typische Eigenschaften der PC-12.)
(Und die nächsten Tage wird er
mit mir als Co-Pilot fliegen.)
(So kann ich ihm
die ganzen Abläufe zeigen.)
Dann muss er mir zeigen,
ob er die Maschine beherrscht.
* Spannende Klänge *
(Ich denke, die grösste
Schwierigkeit im Busch von Botswana
ist das Wetter.)
(V.a. der Wind
und die Temperaturen.)
(Im Sommer kann es im Dschungel
bis zu 38 oder 40 °C heiss werden.)
(Durch die Hitze
ist die Dichte der Luft viel höher
und das Flugzeug hat weniger Schub.)
(Ein Start mit einer schweren Fracht
kann darum
ziemlich schwierig werden.)
* Spannende Klänge *
(Und dann gibt es natürlich Tiere.)
(V.a. beim Start und bei der Landung
sind die
eine grosse Herausforderung.)
(Den Zebras oder Elefanten
sind wir egal.)
(Die bewegen sich einfach nicht.)
Darum fliege ich vor einer Landung
zuerst zwei- oder dreimal
ganz tief über die Piste.)
(Möglichst schnell und möglichst
tief, um sie zu erschrecken.)
(Aber die denken nur:
"Geh weg, das ist mein Platz.")
(Schon als ich zum ersten Mal
mit einer PC-12 geflogen bin,
dachte ich: "Das ist
eine fantastische Maschine.")
(Du kannst sie sehr hoch fliegen
und auch sehr tief.)
(Sie ist schnell
und hat einen starken Motor.)
(Natürlich ist sie kein Jet.)
(Aber für eine Propellermaschine
ist sie top.)
* Pulsierende Klänge *
Allen Berechnungen zum Trotz -
Dominic und Sascha sind nicht
dort gelandet, wo sie hinwollten.
Seit Stunden jagen sie
einer Gewitterzelle hinterher
in der Hoffnung,
dass ein Tornado daraus wird.
Dominic
überprüft laufend die Wetterdaten.
Wir müssen wenden.
Das wird nichts mehr heute.
Der Regen hat die Energie
der gesamten Zelle weggenommen.
Das wird nichts. Tja.
8 Std. Fahrt
für ein paar Regentropfen.
Die Luft bei den Tornadojägern
ist raus.
Eine Zelle lebt durch Energie,
die sie bekommt.
Es war einfach zu kalt.
Und wegen des Niederschlags war
die Energie der Zelle nicht mehr da.
Sie hatte zu wenig Schuss.
Und jetzt
machen wir den Kopf frei für morgen
und lagern die Beine hoch.
Das tut gut.
Es ist nicht selbstverständlich,
dass man einen Tornado sieht.
2009, als ich das erste Mal
hier war, habe ich keinen gesehen.
Man sieht vielleicht
schöne Gewitter, schöne Bilder,
aber das ist es auch schon.
Tornados sind die Zugabe.
Trotzdem:
Die zwei Freunde sind enttäuscht.
Sie wollten heute
einen Tornado fotografieren.
Damit der Tag nicht ganz
verloren ist, halten sie an,
um ein paar Gewitterfotos zu machen.
* Donnergrollen *
Jetzt hat man es gehört.
- Das war genau oberhalb von uns.
Wenn ich fotografiere,
halte ich meine Beine zusammen.
Wenn ein Blitz
in der Nähe einschlägt,
geht er so nicht durch den Körper.
Wenn die Beine auseinander sind,
ist der Widerstand weniger gross
als wenn er der Erde entlang geht.
Wenn ich sie zusammen halte,
geht der Blitz unten durch,
wo der Widerstand
nicht so gross ist.
Und dann hat man auch kein Problem.
Aber die Blitze bleiben
glücklicherweise am Horizont
und zaubern dafür eine
wunderschöne Abendstimmung herbei.
* Klicken des Fotoapparats *
Nicht erwischt.
* Klicken *
Diese Szenerie ist wirklich genial.
Die ersten Bilder, die man schiesst,
sind immer die schönsten.
Wir haben nicht erwartet,
dass es so schön wird.
Oh, meine Güte! Der war schön.
* Ruhige Musik *
Strahlend blauer Himmel im Segel-
trainingscamp im deutschen Walldürn.
Jonas lässt den Tag langsam angehen.
* Sie lachen. *
Ich habe dich kommen gehört.
- Verdammt.
Ich habe nicht geschlafen, sondern
die Figuren im Kopf trainiert.
Aber es ist schön,
so an der Sonne zu liegen.
Fertig Löcher in die Luft gestarrt.
Jonas will schliesslich
Schweizermeister werden.
Etwas mehr Disziplin im Training
würde sicher etwas bringen.
Es ist aber schwierig,
weil das Umfeld so kollegial ist.
Man unterhält sich gerne
mit den anderen.
* Spannende Klänge *
Segelkunstflug auf höchstem Niveau
braucht nicht nur Talent,
sondern auch enorm viel Training.
Dazu eine gute mentale Vorbereitung,
Körperbeherrschung und Atemtechnik.
* Spannende Klänge *
In drei Monaten tritt Jonas
in der höchsten Flugkategorie an.
Die neuen schwierigen Figuren
machen ihm noch zu schaffen.
Er muss sie
präzise und elegant fliegen,
um an der Schweizermeisterschaft
genügend Punkte zu machen.
Aber Trainer George hat
auch heute wieder viel auszusetzen.
Da war eine Senkrechte
und ganz wenig Schiebewinkel.
Jetzt stehst du
ganz deutlich übersenkrecht.
Das hat man
schon von Rom aus gesehen.
Zu früh eingefangen.
Zurück auf dem Boden
ist Jonas noch zuversichtlich.
Es war deutlich besser als bisher.
Es gibt sicher noch einige Sachen.
Aber verglichen mit dem letzten Flug
war es sicher ein Unterschied.
Dann holt er sich das Feedback
des Trainers auf dem Diktiergerät.
Jetzt stehst du
ganz deutlich übersenkrecht.
Das hat man
schon von Rom aus gesehen.
Zu früh eingefangen.
Mit dem Querruder
sehr viel nachgesteuert,
das Seitenruder
aber noch stehen lassen.
Dadurch hattest du
einen grossen Schiebewinkel.
(Als ich das gehört hatte,
dachte ich mir: "Scheisse.")
("Fliege ich so schlecht?")
Schätzungsweise noch ...
... 300 oder 400 Trainingsflüge in
den nächsten zwei bis drei Jahren,
damit hier eine Präzision reinkommt.
Wie gesagt: Er fliegt
einen einigermassen guten Standard.
Aber er fliegt noch
keine Achter- oder Neunerfiguren.
Er fliegt auch ...
Na gut, es ist Figurentraining.
Er fliegt auch noch viele Dinge
etwas zu unruhig.
Er muss noch
Ruhe und Eleganz reinbringen.
Diese harsche Kritik
ist Jonas nicht gewohnt.
In drei Monaten findet
die Schweizermeisterschaft statt.
Der junge Weltmeister reist mit einem
unguten Gefühl zurück in die Schweiz.
Dort teilt Jonas sich seit Kurzem
eine Wohnung
mit seiner Freundin Anna.
Es ist ein wenig scharf.
- Ja.
Die beiden sind schon
seit sechs Jahren zusammen.
Anna weiss,
dass Jonas' grösste Leidenschaft
immer das Fliegen sein wird.
Mal schauen,
ob ich das ganze Bier trinke.
Zum Wohl.
- Zum Wohl.
Zeit,
um etwas Gemeinsames zu unternehmen,
bleibt dem jungen Paar wenig.
Ich wünsche mir manchmal,
dass Jonas
am Wochenende mehr Zeit hat.
Dann könnten wir
auch mal wandern gehen.
Immer zu Ende der Saison
nehme ich mir vor,
das nächste Jahr weniger zu fliegen,
nicht
an so viele Wettbewerbe zu gehen.
Wenn super Flugwetter ist,
möchte ich
lieber nichts mit Jonas unternehmen.
Gleich so?
- Ja, definitiv.
Dann lasse ich dich lieber
fliegen gehen.
Dann musst du nächstes Mal fragen,
ob ich dich mitnehme.
Ja.
- Das wäre die bessere Lösung.
Ob es dafür reichen wird?
Jonas weiss, dass er
noch sehr viel trainieren muss,
um in der höchsten Kategorie
fliegen zu können.
* Ruhige Musik *
Wenn Daniel Moser startet,
geht es nicht um einen Wettbewerb,
sondern um Leben und Tod.
Der Berner ist Missionspilot
für die internationale christliche
Hilfsorganisation MAF in Osttimor,
einer Halbinsel in Südostasien.
Heute muss er
zwei Patienten transportieren.
Ein elfjähriger Junge
mit Verdacht auf Denguefieber
und ein kleines Neugeborenes
mit Atemnot müssen ins Spital.
* Sie sprechen unverständlich. *
Dem Baby gehe es nicht gut.
Wir müssen uns beeilen.
Die Strassen sind schlecht. Es
kommt nur ein Flugtransport infrage.
Aber die Propellermaschine kann
höchstens fünf Personen mitnehmen.
Ich kann nur die zwei Patienten und
je ein Familienmitglied mitnehmen.
Und den Arzt.
(Ich bin
ein stark sachorientierter Mensch.)
(Mir fällt es oft schwer,
mich in andere Leute einzufühlen.)
(Das ist sicher von Vorteil,
wenn ich in der Situation bin.)
(Dann blende ich das aus.)
(Aber manchmal holt es mich ein,
wenn ich in ein Gesicht schaue.)
(Bei Kindern ist es oft ...)
Als Eli noch klein war ...
Ich hielt den Kleinen auf dem Arm
und wusste,
dass jemand
gerade mit den Tränen kämpft
und das Leben
gerade nicht so schön findet.
Der Schweizer hat gelernt,
mit den oft belastenden Situationen
seines Berufsalltags umzugehen.
Als Rettungspilot
muss Daniel pragmatisch entscheiden.
Emotionen
haben im Cockpit nichts zu suchen.
(Es kann schon sein,
dass es mir sehr nahe geht.)
(Z.B. wenn ich sehe,
dass Kinder sterben.)
(Oder Teenager.
Das ist wirklich schwierig.)
(Es gibt kein Cockpit,
das von der Kabine abgekapselt ist.)
(Ich kriege alles mit.)
Ich glaube, es besteht die Gefahr,
einfach wegzuschauen
und auszublenden.
Aber das kann ich hier nicht.
Ich bin täglich damit konfrontiert.
Mir bleibt nur etwas übrig:
dankbar zu sein.
Es ist nicht selbstverständlich,
dass die Familie gesund ist,
dass es uns gut geht
und wir Unterstützung haben.
Es ist schon schwierig, ja.
Das kann man
nicht einfach ausblenden.
Ob die beiden Kinder
überleben werden,
wird Daniel
erst in ein paar Tagen erfahren.
* Skype-Anrufton *
Hallo.
Wie geht's euch?
Schau.
Du kannst Tante Andrea Hallo sagen.
Hallo!
Oh, nein. Nein, Eli.
Warte.
Ich habe irgendetwas gedrückt.
(Deborah) (Am schwersten fällt mir,
dass wir so weit weg sind.)
Zu Beginn fiel es mir sehr schwer,
wenn es nicht geklappt hat.
Wenn das Internet nicht ging - das
hat mich jeweils traurig gemacht.
Hallo.
Wann rasierst du dich endlich mal?
(Mann) Hä?
- Wann rasierst du dich?
Nie mehr.
- Nie mehr?
Die Grosseltern in der Schweiz sehen
den kleinen Eli nur einmal pro Woche,
übers Internet.
Jetzt sehen sie dich. Sag: "Gute
Nacht, Grossmama und Grosspapa."
Schlaf gut, Eli.
Siehst du? Simon, Andrea, Grosspapa.
Bis nächsten Sonntag.
- Macht's gut.
Ihr auch. Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Ade.
Die Samstagabende oder die Sonntage,
die wir gemeinsam verbringen,
fehlen.
Definitiv.
Irgendwann gehen wir wieder zurück.
Niemand weiss, wann.
Ja.
Kann ich dir helfen?
In Argentinien
ist es endlich so weit.
Stefan und sein Team
starten zur Fahrt über die Anden.
* Ergreifende Musik *
Der Startplatz
liegt auf 2'500 m Höhe.
Aber die Ballonteams
wollen noch viel weiter hinauf -
bis auf 7'000 m werden sie steigen.
* Jubelrufe *
* Epische Musik *
Und die Sauerstoffflasche
funktioniert.
Hier über die Ohren.
Und jetzt hier unten festziehen.
* Rauschen des Brenners *
Wir sind auf 4'500 m, bald 4'600 m.
Wir steigen mit 2,5 bis 3,5 m.
Wir kommen jetzt ungefähr
auf Gipfelhöhe.
* Rauschen des Brenners *
Obwohl Stefan in 20 Jahren
rund 2'000 Fahrten gemacht hat,
geht für ihn heute
ein Traum in Erfüllung.
Es ist etwas vom Allerschönsten.
Ich durfte schon
viel Schönes erleben.
Aber das hier ist wirklich ... geil.
Es fühlt sich an
wie Weihnachten und Ostern zusammen.
Und nächste Woche
bei "Schweizer Helden der Lüfte":
Dominic und Sascha
finden eine Gewitterzelle
und versuchen,
ihre Konkurrenz abzuhängen.
Wenn ich einen Wunsch hätte ...
Könntest du etwas schneller fahren?
Aber nur, wenn es geht.
Stefan
gerät über den Anden in Turbulenzen.
Wie hoch sind wir?
- 2'600 m.
Jetzt kann es für einen Moment
ungemütlich werden.
Jonas erhält einen Anruf, der all
seine Pläne über den Haufen wirft.
Wenn ich alleine
bei Unlimited fliegen würde,
kann ich auch nicht
Schweizermeister werden.
Und Misha hat einen Notfall
auf einer Safari-Range.